regardez regardez ce que j'ai là j'ai
cette énorme boite énorme boite du
Galaxy book 3
ultra qui est énorme alors c'est un
ordinateur attention soyons calme soyons
clairs c'est le très gros ordinateur et
très cher aussi de Samsung qui est là
galaxie BO3 ultra alors c'est vraiment
qui a été présenté c'est pas tout
nouveau mais moi je prends mon temps
vous voyez tranquillement on teste on
s'amuse on se fait plaisir donc
aujourd'hui on va se regarder ce Galaxy
boom 3 ultra qui est énorme on va
regarder ce qu'il fait ce qu'il le fait
bien est-ce qu'il est intéressant soyons
clairs on va se dire jusque l'année
dernière Samsung est revenu avec les
Galaxy book 2 sur le marché français il
continuait à des ordinateurs mais dans
le reste du monde pas en France et
c'était dommage donc ils ont corrigé ça
ils sont revenus alors avec des machines
très cool et il leur manquait des des
petits trucs et ils sont nuls compléter
ça avec ce portable qui est là un petit
peu pour concurrencer les MacBook avec
les puces MBA pro M1 ultra m2 Apple pour
autant je pense que c'est pas réellement
le sujet ici le sujet c'est de voir ce
truc là très beau truc attention je
tiens à préciser réellement avec une
piscine telle on fait un tour complet le
panorama à 360 degrés cette machine et
puis vous me direz la fin vous ce que
vous en pensez ce qui vous plaît vous
plaît pas surtout ça tout ça après le
générique allez on y va c'est parti
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec iveca VPN
penser à venir protéger vos appareils
notamment ici votre Galaxy book3 ultra
protéger également votre smartphone sur
Android si vous avez un Mac peut
protéger votre Mac si vous avez un
iPhone vous pouvez protéger votre iPhone
bref vous pouvez protéger tous vos
appareils à la maison ça c'est vachement
bien et notamment ici avec ivpn alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'il vous faut un VPN
un VPN ça vient créer un tunnel crypté
afin de garantir votre sécurité votre
confidentialité que personne ne puisse
venir récupérer votre contenu à droite à
gauche notamment si vous êtes dans un
wifi public imaginez vous êtes dans un
hôtel et bien personne va pouvoir venir
arriver et aspirer le contenu
directement que vous êtes en train de
consulter vos données perso sont
protégées vous êtes sûr d'avoir une
totale confidentialité par rapport au
site sur lesquels vous êtes en train de
naviguer vous êtes peinard et ça c'est
vachement bien ce qui fait que aucun
pirate qui est connecté au même réseau
que vous ne pourra venir intercepter vos
données personnelles en plus d'avoir
cette sécurité vous avez un anonymat sur
internet c'est quand même très très cool
vous avez un accès au contenu qui sont
géo bloqués je pense notamment à Netflix
Disney plus prime vidéo et compagnie
certaines séries et films seront
disponibles dans dans un pays et pas
dans d'autres donc vous n'avez qu'à
venir vous connecter grâce à votre VPN
au serveur dispo dans un autre pays par
exemple ici aux Etats-Unis pour avoir
accès au contenu dispo uniquement aux
États-Unis et pas en France et ça c'est
vachement bien ça vous protège je vous
le disais dans les Wi-Fi public ça c'est
cool vous êtes Intraçable les
cybercriminels sont bloqués bref vous
êtes tranquille et ça c'est vachement
bien et en plus de ça arrive aussi VPN
ne garde absolument aucune donnée sur ce
que vous avez consulté il y a aucun log
en plus ici vous pouvez connecter
jusqu'à 10 appareils en simultané votre
smartphone votre PC votre télé notamment
en plus ici vous avez un chiffrement 256
bits militaires autant dire que vous
donnez sont sécurisées et ça c'est
chouette une offre de fou sur le site
VPN si vous souscrivez un abonnement de
5 ans vous payez
0,90 centimes par mois soit 56 euros en
tout avec en plus de ça le gestionnaire
de mot de passe inclus autant vous dire
que c'est vraiment pas cher votre
connexion est sécurisée ou que vous
soyez et ça c'est vachement bien une
fois de plus je vous mets le lien en bas
dans la description et merci à y décidez
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo ils nous
ont fait un truc cool un truc très gros
intéressant c'est cette très grosse
machine alors pour autant cette très
grosse machine elle est pas trop trop
lourde la taille elle fait 1 kg 79 elle
est assez fine malgré tout regardez hop
la tac tac on peut se voir à travers
comme ça elle est assez légère mais par
contre elle est assez massive elle est
assez massive pourquoi parce qu'en fait
à l'intérieur vous avez un grand écran
de 16 pouces c'est une grosse bête un
plat à 14 empreinte digitale je pose mon
doigt tac Pat ça déverrouille vous voyez
c'est un waouh passe pas tomber ça
serait con de le péter c'est un très
très grand écran très très belle dalle
on se parle ici effectivement d'une
belle dalle de 16 pouces et cette belle
dalle de 16 pouces moi elle me plaît
beaucoup pourquoi et bien parce que elle
est franchement hyper cool elle est très
grande diagonale on s'en doutera c'est
du 16 pouces c'est grand c'est beau
résolution 3K c'est du
2880 par 1800 pixels c'est grand c'est
très grand et ça c'est très bien alors
il a un côté où il rit très
réfléchissant on se voit quand même bien
à travers donc attention quand même au
reflet c'est pas une Dalmat c'est une
dalle qui est brillante qui pour le coup
est très brillante on voit bien à
travers c'est une dalle dynamique à
molette 2x c'est la même dalle qui met
dans leur smartphone et plus haut de
gamme vous avez ici un Galaxy S23 ultra
que je vais déverrouiller tout de suite
c'est également une dalle dynamique à
Mol 2x donc en fait c'est la même techno
qui viennent intégrer entre d'un côté ce
grand truc là et ce petit truc là dans
techno très bien maîtrisé je sais pas si
vous le savez ça me saoule fabrique des
écrans c'est Samsung display là ceux qui
vous vendent des ordinateurs c'est
Samsung electronique c'est une autre
division de chez Samsung mais tout ça
c'est du Samsung et c'est fait maison
c'est également un écran qui va
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz alors on se dirait ok 120 Hertz
pour du gaming je suis pas vraiment
convaincu que cet ordinateur soit fait
pour faire du gaming même si on peut en
faire vous verrez que vous avez une
configuration
c'est la série H qu'on peut faire quand
même pas mal de choses avec mais pour
moi il est plus pour les créatifs pour
tous ceux qui veulent et bien prendre
leur smartphone faire une vidéo faire
des photos tac avec quickshare ils en
voie directement leurs photos sur leur
ordi et ensuite ils viennent les éditer
photos avec Lightroom veut dire shooter
en haut là-dessus d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo vous pouvez shooter avec
votre Galaxy S23 ultra qui est juste
incroyable vous shootez en rond vous
envoyez vous éditez directement avec
Lightroom vous faites votre montage avec
Première Pro ou d'autres si vous voulez
peu importe et c'est plutôt vraiment
cette machine qui est destinée pour moi
pour les créatifs et ça qui m'intéresse
ici donc le 120 Hertz je m'en fous un
petit peu parce que de toute façon j'en
aurai pas réellement le besoin ici mais
bon si vous voulez faire tourner des
jeux attention vous pouvez vous avez
quand même une Nvidia une Geforce RTX 40
50 qui est avec le i7 et vous avez la
4070 avec le i9 donc bon vous voyez
c'est quand même sérieux ça déconne pas
mais c'est là où c'est marrant c'est à
dire que quand ils viennent se
positionner enfin quand il charge même
si il le disent pas même si c'est pas
Samsung qui prend la parole là tu soyons
clair et quand on vous dit et c'est ce
que je vois un peu à droite à gauche
quand je vais regarder un peu je vois
pas avec des copains avec des collègues
on se dit souvent ils viennent chercher
les créatifs tous ceux qui partent chez
Apple sur un MacBook Pro que j'ai
foutrement par là-bas avec une puce à ma
pro et mon ultra ou une m2 je suis
d'accord mais pour autant on est sur
l'Intel c'est pas exactement la même
chose ça marche toujours mieux là-bas
ils ont franchement bien gros coup de
pied dans la fourmilière Apple avec leur
Apple silicone ce qui est juste
incroyable mais si vous voulez venir
travailler sérieusement du Photoshop du
premier Pro vous avez franchement ce
qu'il faut là-dessus là-dessus il y a
aucun problème et alors petit point de
détail vous avez un temps de réponse de
0,2 millisecondes et c'est une dalle qui
est également là pour lutter contre la
lumière bleue contre la fatigue oculaire
donc on peut venir bosser de longues
sessions ici sans souffrir et sans venir
flinguer les yeux donc ça c'est cool bon
après on passe tout de technique gamme
de couleur sont 20% des 6 pétrons on
s'en fout un peu moi ce qui me plaît
bien aussi c'est cette finition qui est
assez classique je dirais que ici ça me
saoule qui a pas pris trop de risques
mais c'est classique c'est efficace
c'est le l'aluminium anthracite que
j'aime bien alors après il y a d'autres
capteurs qui sont assez simples
efficaces comme on dit effectivement
pour les créatifs et bien on va venir
leur mettre quoi au créatif on va venir
leur mettre un petit port Micro SD comme
ça quand vous avez shooté avec un
boîtier ou que sais-je encore vous
pouvez bien vous brancher ici après si
vous avez besoin vous avez de l'USB à
3.2 ok ça c'est cool prise jack micro et
casque pour les streamers soit en tout
cas c'est pas obligé mais si vous voulez
vous pouvez vous avez ici de l'HDMI 2.0
ok et vous avez ici deux prises
thunderbol 4 c'est le SBC ce qui est un
peu relou soyons clair c'est que vous
venez vous recharger ici avec un
chargeur de 100 W je crois c'est 200
watts mais lui il est en USB c'est ce
qui fait que lorsque vous le branchez
lui vous avez besoin de vous recharger
ce qui arrive quand même assez
régulièrement pas tout le temps mais ça
arrive tu comptes pas vraiment chercher
sur un premier Pro vous avez d'autres
logiciels qui tournent à côté il y a un
moment il faut bien se recharger et bien
il vous reste plus qu'une seule prise
USB thunderbol 4 ce qui fait que vous
voulez venir brancher un moniteur vous
allez le faire avec une seule prise
overboard en deuxième moniteur si vous
le souhaitez ici en HDMI mais je trouve
ça con que ça vient de me piquer
celle-là est-ce que il aurait pas valu
soit Samsung veuillez rajouter un autre
USB c'est de l'autre côté sunderbol 4 ou
alors mettre un port propriétaire ou je
sais pas quelle porte pour ne pas venir
me condamner ce truc là voilà ça c'est
toi qui a un peu le petit bémol et je
trouve ça un peu con bon au-delà de ça
on a quand même pas mal de choses pour
venir se connecter et ça c'est bien donc
le design est cool l'écran est très bien
super bien calibré j'aime beaucoup la
finesse que vous avez là aussi vous avez
vraiment la dalle qui est posée juste
au-dessus là du côté du châssis et ça
vous donne un look qui est vraiment
magnifique donc ça c'est vraiment
vraiment top j'aime beaucoup aussi le
fait que on est des bords qui soient
quand même relativement fin avec cette
petite webcam qui est cachée alors
petite certes mais petite mais sérieuse
on se parle ici d'une cam en 1080p et
cette cam en 1080p pour bien travailler
elle ira bien alors attention à parler
des finitions foufou ça reste malgré
tout tout petit capteur qui est planqué
juste là mais pour venir collaborer pour
venir faire un peu de création aussi et
ça vous pouvez le faire après si vous
voulez aller plus loin il va falloir
venir acheter une webcam soyons clairs
alors puisque c'est un PC qui est là
pour créatif on va s'attendre et
notamment comme moi si vous faites du
montage vidéo est-ce que au niveau audio
ça envoie un peu de pâté vous avez
quatre haut-parleurs alors là haut
parleur là par là haut parleur là haut
parleur ils sont planqués par là et en
fait vous avez quatre par là mais vous
avez du son stéréo gauche droite vous
avez pas un espèce de 4 points je sais
pas quoi non stéréo mais avec quatre
haut-parleurs pour l'image justement
stéréoscopie pour venir disperser le son
un petit peu partout en plus de ça c'est
un son à 4G il faut savoir qu'à 4G c'est
une boîte qui était racheté il y a
quelques années par Samsung qui fait
donc partie du groupe Samsung donc
maintenant dès que vous avez de l'audio
chez Samsung c'est signé AKG et vous le
marque juste en bas si vous regardez
bien son bail AKG vous avez également du
Dolby Atmos vous pouvez venir je vous le
dis vous connecter soit avec votre prise
Jack qui est là pour venir brancher un
casque sinon vous pouvez vous connecter
sans fil grâce au Bluetooth 5.1 soit en
utilisant les haut-parleurs directement
inclus dans votre PC bien évidemment
regardez je vais vous le mettre bien
fort
voilà alors
vous êtes un peu de son c'est que c'est
compliqué de se rendre compte comme ça
premier retour sur l'audio je trouve
qu'il y a un truc qui est pas mal ici
c'est que on a une belle image à
stéréoscopie ça c'est le truc qu'ils ont
vraiment réussi c'est à dire que vous
avez vraiment le son vous voyez qui
vient un peu par là c'est très étiré et
qui vient un peu par là donc ça c'est
pas mal et ça ça me plaît bien
maintenant le truc que je vais aimer un
peu moins je trouve que le son est un
petit peu trop médium et si vous venez
mettre en face un macbook pro depuis le
premier 16 pouces qui étaient sur Intel
et bien ça n'a rien à voir c'est le jour
et la nuit la qualité bien meilleure là
alors après à la décharge de Samsung il
y a très peu de machines qui font aussi
bien que ce que fait Apple au niveau de
l'audio donc bon c'est pas déconnant
mais c'est vrai que quand on a goûté un
truc qui est très très bon et qu'on est
sur un PC à plus de 3000 balles on
voudrait un peu mieux surtout quand on a
une marque audio signée AKG on se dirait
je veux vraiment que ça envoie un peu du
bois une fois de plus je tire pas du
tout sur Samsung parce qu'ils sont pas
les seuls à faire ça donc je pense que
vraiment Apple a réussi à tirer son
épargne du jeu et ici c'est dommage ce
truc que j'aime bien c'est la
stéréoscopie après pour venir travailler
si vous voulez une bonne expérience
audio ou même pour venir jouer mettez un
casque alors attention instant
prévention si vous mettez un casque vous
jouez pas pendant des heures à un volume
de fou vous travaillez pas pendant des
heures un volume de fou faites attention
faites des pauses pensez à préserver vos
oreilles ça c'est super important parce
que petit détail vous avez quand même
deux Twitter de 2 et de woofer de vous
faire c'est pas grave de vous faire de
cinq watts mais pour moi ça manque
encore un petit peu de rondeur il
faudrait venir le chercher un peu plus
alors puisqu'on est sur un PC qui est là
pour les créatifs les créatifs ils
veulent quoi quand ils créent ils
veulent que ça rampe pas ils veulent que
ça avance alors je vous l'ai dit on est
sur un Intel Core de 13e génération
c'est la série H i7 i9 certifié et vous
en plus vous avez quand même 32 Go donc
franchement ça va il y a de quoi faire
pour faire du montage et du multical sur
Photoshop le travail du Lightroom d'une
application à l'autre vous aurez pas de
souci c'est puissance et fluide c'est
très efficace en terme de stockage vous
avez un SSD c'est du PCE vous avez
intérêt un Téra en natif à l'intérieur
de la bébête vous allez voir il y a des
options je vais vous montrer tout à
l'heure on va regarder les différentes
configurations qui existent mais
globalement un terrasse ça me paraît pas
dégueu après deux terrains ça aurait été
pas mal je crois qu'il y a pas d'options
de terrain je vais pas dire de bêtises
ce que je vous recommande quand même
après c'est de dire brancher si vous
souhaitez travailler un petit disque ici
sur le Nord bol 4 vous réussirez à bien
travailler un petit peu avec un disque
externe et voyez que le truc qui est un
peu relou rapidement c'est que si vous
branchez un disque externe si vous
branchez votre chargeur et bien va
arriver un moment PAF vous avez plus de
thunderbol 4 et ça c'est un petit peu
couillon et j'aurais bien aimé qu'il y
en a yant de plus bon après vous me
direz vous branchez le moniteur vous
branchez le disque dur vous branchez la
charge et là tout ce côté-là déjà il est
pris mon Tintin donc voilà un petit peu
alors il y a un autre truc qui très très
très bien et que ça j'aime beaucoup ce
que nous a fait ici Samsung et bien
c'est ce très gros trackpad ça il est
bien beaucoup de constructeurs de temps
en temps nous mettre des tracks pas d'un
peu plus petit alors qu'ils ont
franchement à la place là ils sont venus
vraiment totalement utiliser l'espace
comme ce que vous aurez sur un MacBook
Pro donc ça c'est bien bravo Samsung
j'adore j'ai un grand trackpad il est
fluide il est agréable personnellement
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
également ce clavier je le trouve
extrêmement complet donc ça c'est aussi
un point très très fort alors bon moi
j'ai un beau clavier AZERTY ici j'ai
toutes mes touches fonctions sur le haut
et j'ai ici tout mon impact sur le côté
qui me plaît beaucoup donc ça c'est
vachement même donc ça c'est bien pour
tous les créatifs mais c'est aussi cool
pour les gamers parce que il y en a qui
ont vraiment l'habitude de venir jouer
comme ça d'ailleurs la plupart je pense
donc ça c'est bien et pour autant il y a
vraiment de l'espace entre les touches
le confort est très très bon il y a un
toucher qui est très agréable très bon
retour de touche je trouve que ça c'est
un truc qui est vraiment bien réussi que
ce soit aussi bien le trackpad aussi
bien le clavier pour moi l'expérience
ici elle est vraiment super bonne tout
en sachant que et bah oui regardez ici
vous avez quand même un capteur
d'empreinte digitale regardez je vais
venir hop là un peu plus large vous
allez voir je pose mon doigt tac ça
déverrouille directement alors c'est pas
la grosse innovation du siècle mais
c'est quand même cool parce que ça
permet de déverrouiller facilement donc
ça une fois de plus c'est un petit
détail mais ce point de détail il a son
importance et ça ça me plaît en plus de
ça il est cool parce que tout comme mon
galaxy S23 ultra et bien lui se ultra
ici il a du wifi ce donc pour venir se
connecter rapidement agent à votre
dernière box wifi ce par exemple de
Bouygues Telecom chez vous et ben vous
pouvez le faire ça c'est bien et il a un
indice de réparabilité de 8,7 sur 10
donc si il y a un souci on sait qu'on
peut venir changer des choses et venir
réparer un petit peu la machine donc ça
aussi c'est rassurant et puis après
toute l'expérience logiciel et bien elle
tourne sur Windows Home ici donc ça
c'est cool également alors je vais pas
vous donner une petite histoire sur
Windows on connaît l'histoire on connaît
Windows on s'en fout un peu par contre
moi ce qui m'intéresse la notion
d'écosystème que développe de plus en
plus Samsung il y a quelques années ça
me saoule de présenter produit par
produit vous avez tiens voilà notre
nouveau smartphone tiens voilà nos
écouteurs tiens voilà notre tablette et
puis un jour ils sont dit tiens si on en
parlait plus que maintenant ensemble de
choses qui vous permettent de travailler
très facilement d'un appareil à l'autre
et de communiquer très facilement la
notion d'écosystème a continué d'éclore
et d'exploser et de plus en plus
présente chez Samsung chez les autres
mais c'est Samsung aussi ça c'est un
truc ou Apple était vraiment en avance
et où les autres sont vraiment venus
rattraper leur retard et ça me saoule
ici un écosystème très complet pourquoi
parce que vous avez bien évidemment le
smartphone qui est au cœur de
l'écosystème vous avez les écouteurs
vous avez la tablette vous avez bien
évidemment votre PC et puis ça va
beaucoup plus loin parce que si vous
avez l'application maison Smart things
et piloter la domotique vous pouvez
venir piloter votre plaque à induction
vous pouvez venir piloter votre four
votre réfrigérateur bref vous me pilotez
l'ensemble de la maison et c'est là où
Samsung va beaucoup plus loin que ce que
fait Apple parce que Apple jusqu'à
preuve du contraire ne fabrique toujours
pas de plaque à induction de
réfrigérateur de four de haute connectée
et que ça j'ai encore et ça c'est la
très grosse force de Samsung
c'est-à-dire que ils ont vraiment une
vision complète pour la maison à 360
degrés donc vous avez d'un côté le
côté ici et tout ça avec au centre votre
smartphone de Samsung et ça c'est
vraiment bien alors moi ce que j'aime
bien c'est que vous pouvez connecter
très facilement votre smartphone
regardez ici à votre PC vous allez dans
votre smartphone et vous veniez sur la
petite case s'appelle lia Windows vous
voyez il est déjà lié donc je laisse
appuyer et Tac j'arrive sur lien avec
Windows hop là qui est là avec les
différentes options et puis après vous
avez des petites options et si elle ça
et lorsque vous arrivez sur votre
ordinateur vous avez ici votre mobile
connecté je vais avoir différentes
choses je vais retrouver mon smartphone
ici avec marqué Galaxy S23 ultra je vois
qu'il est connecté j'ai mon niveau de
batterie j'ai ma configuration ok je
vais retrouver mes messages mes appels
mes photos mes différentes applications
ça c'est marrant parce que vous voyez si
je vais sur mes photos je fais des
filets j'ai toutes les photos qu'il y a
dans mon smartphone alors bon faut tant
qu'elle se charge mais elles sont bien
ici donc ça c'est mes photos donc là
j'ai mes différentes applications qui
sont dans mon smartphone si par exemple
je me dis ben tiens je vais venir me
lancer un petit asphalt 9 oui
typiquement ici j'ai un 29 je clique et
là lui il me demande sur mon smartphone
démarrer l'enregistrement de la
diffusion lien avec Windows ici donc là
je fais commencer et là je se retrouve
avec mon asphalt 9 directement ici
clavier connecté evolmark donc vous
voyez là j'ai mon jeu directement sur
mon pc je fais nouveau je choisis ma
bagnole et je joue alors après c'est
l'aventure parce que c'est vraiment pas
un jeu qui a optimisé pour jouer sur
ordi ah ouais donc là elle barre
d'espacement ça marche ça met le turbo
ah et après
S et là pour déraper recharger la loge
de nitro ah c'est génial bon bref faut
jouer à demain et là vous voyez j'ai la
prise par la caméra mais je peux venir
le faire tourner directement donc voyez
un côté pratique alors ce truc qui est
un peu relou c'est qu'en fait le son
vient de là et le son vient pas de du PC
je sais pas pourquoi c'est assez bizarre
mais je peux venir faire tourner des
applications de mon smartphone
directement ici alors après de la même
manière et bien je peux venir
directement prendre mon smartphone je
peux faire un copier coller de l'autre
côté je peux venir envoyer des messages
ici je veux dire prendre des appels
directement ici et ce qui est cool c'est
que si j'ai des bots par exemple et bien
hop là je suis avec mes Galaxy boss je
reçois un appel je suis en train
d'écouter de la musique ici en train de
travailler directement avec mes bugs ou
un casque peu importe et bien pas je
vais switcher l'audio là et je peux
prendre des appels directement ici
depuis mon ordi donc j'ai toute cette
notion d'écosystème qui est vachement
bien et qui vous permet de faire
travailler tous vos appareils de Samsung
ensemble alors là je vous le montre sur
un Galaxy S23 ultra mais vous pourrez
aussi faire des choses très bien sur un
autre smartphone de Samsung sans aucun
problème et d'ailleurs sur n'importe
quel autre smartphone qui a la
fonctionnalité liée à Windows et ça il y
en a quelques-uns donc vous voyez c'est
très très bien vous avez donc votre
smartphone ici un Galaxy S23 ultra qui
est au centre de l'écosystème je viens
utiliser ensuite avec mon PC pour tout
le côté collaboratif le côté traitement
de texte ce côté récupération d'image
vous prenez des photos tag vous les
prenez vous les glissez vous les déposez
c'est très complet et je trouve ça cool
et c'est en ça que cet ordinateur est
très chouette au-delà d'être puissant
au-delà des performant et bien on peut
faire quand même pas mal de choses avec
et ça c'est vraiment bien après ce
Galaxy book 3 ultra bien évidemment on
peut venir l'acheter sur le site de
Samsung on s'en doutera vous avez
différentes config alors vous allez voir
je vais faire autrement pour venir vous
montrer on va aller directement là donc
on part de principe qu'on fait pas une
reprise le Galaxy book 3 ultra à partir
de 3299 € et d'ailleurs vous voyez il y
a une offre là moniteur 22 pouces
offerts plus 300 euros de bonus reprises
je pense sur votre ancien pc donc ça
veut dire que vous avez la valeur de
résiduelle de votre ancien PC plus 300
euros de bonus repris c'est quand même
pas dégueu comme offre une fois de plus
ça vous intéresse je vous mets un lien
juste en bas dans la description alors
c'est forcément de Windows 11 32 Go ici
on s'en doutera là un terrain stockage
alors vous voyez normalement c'est
3499 euros là il y a des promos à 3299
euros donc déjà 200 balles de prix c'est
quand même pas mal et il vous le marque
le 1-t au prix du 512 je pense que c'est
pour ça que le 512 n'existe pas ici
couleur il y en a qu'une et là vous
choisissez donc forcément 16 pouces
alors il y a une différence au niveau du
cross si vous prenez un i7 vous êtes à
3299 si vous prenez un i neuf 3000 699
400 balles de plus quand même pour avoir
le i9 par rapport au i7 alors vous le
voyez il sait c'est une RTX 45 50 i9
c'est une RTX 40 70 on est tout de suite
à 3699 euros et là
3299 euros après pour venir soit
l'acheter soit le louer et puis vous
allez à différentes options Samsung et
compagnies c'est plutôt marrant vous
voyez 300 euros de bonus repris ça c'est
très très très bien et le moniteur 22
pouces Samsung qui vous est offert
franchement c'est pas dégueux et là il
vous le montre je vous l'avais dit tout
à l'heure mais il vous le montre
l'indice de réparabilité de 8,7 sur 10
donc moi c'est un PC je trouve super
cool le format est bien le format est
canon c'est peut-être pas le PC que
j'irai fatalement comme ça dire bah
tiens pour le gaming c'est celui-là sur
lequel vous allez aller il y en a
d'autres qui sont peut-être plus typés
mais pour avoir un PC très exigeant plus
dédié créatif avec une machine
performante avec de belles options
jusqu'à un i neuve qui est très cool et
franchement quand vous mettez déjà 3300
balles mieux vaut rajouter 400 balles de
plus même si ça reste quand même
beaucoup d'argent pour monter en U9 vous
allez vraiment gagner en terme de
performance et côté graphique avec la
4070 ça c'est quand même vachement cool
vous avez en plus une belle batterie de
76w bref une machine que j'aime bien qui
est cool qui est un peu grande mais bon
voilà c'est du 16 pouces on en a pour
son argent donc si elle vous intéresse
une fois de plus vous met un lien dans
la description si vous êtes créatif si
vous voulez aller faire des montages si
vous voulez faire de l'édition photo si
vous voulez jouer aussi on peut venir
jouer mais c'est pas trop mon usage donc
j'ai pas trop vous en parler c'est très
très bien après on ira pas aussi loin
que ce qu'on va retrouver chez Apple sur
un MacBook Pro en termes de performance
brute soyons clairs l'expérience audio
et aussi en dessous soyons clairs un
tarif équivalent mais si vous voulez un
très bon pc sur Windows très haut de
gamme qui en plus de ça va être full
compatible avec votre smartphone Samsung
et bien ici vous avez vraiment une très
très jolie bête et une fois de plus vous
intéresse vous avez le lien juste en bas
voilà dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez comment vous le trouvez ce Galaxy
book3 ultra est-ce qu'il vous plaît vous
plaît pas vous êtes vos iPad dites-moi
tout ça bien évidemment en bas dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve
bientôt pour continuer à parler tech de
Samsung et les autres ça c'est bien je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]